yeah i think that the market's always  continuously evolving and yeah some  people want to go into an internal  recruitment role but i personally think  there's no better time to be an external  recruiter right now because there's so  many jobs obviously you're seeing in the  market that a lot of internals are  getting cut from small to large  companies just down to the market  conditions so i think there's definitely  experience from both sides both an  agency versus internal roles um but i  think they're the chance to work in  specific areas and work with multiple  clients is very attractive to people and  yeah we may lose a couple of recruiters  to internal roles but we kind of expect  that it just depends on the personality  of the  certain recruiter and what what stage of  their career that they're at the  recruitment mentors podcast is proudly  sponsored by vincerie and the  award-winning sauce breaker